[Music]
see what happens in your team up with
[ __ ] Bobby Knight [ __ ] trump
V Joey where the [ __ ] you've been a bit
busy all day I got two minutes to smoke
a bowl with you [ __ ] and I'm
back on the road I gotta go to Hollywood
I gotta go to a [ __ ] movie penny I
got the store at 11 I got dinner you
know then it's been like this all
[ __ ] dead and stop today I don't
really think I forgot about you
[ __ ] but enough is enough
before this journey I gotta gets known
to the [ __ ] and who's better to
get stop with that my favorite [ __ ]
people in the world who smoke it's a
[ __ ] presidential [ __ ] from
Sunset herbal over here the home for the
[ __ ] Red Devil stars you know and you
know me I'm just putting the pieces
together I'm just like you fight for my
[ __ ] life every day a man in combat
knives bad that's bazookas but don't
matter cuz it's all for you by the [ __ ]
is gonna take over these [ __ ]
- [ __ ] Ted Cruz's father killed cat I
love fun I love it I love all this duck
[ __ ] these white people they believe all
this [ __ ] so me and you we don't give a
[ __ ] with too busy smoking the herbal
debt
I love it no stars today but do a few
meetings little jiu-jitsu I got the [ __ ]
kicked out of me ballet who's better
than me once you get [ __ ] choked out
at jujitsu who's gonna stop you the rest
of the [ __ ] day old prince get the
[ __ ] out of my face you know how we do
it
but that's it that's it that's all you
know I don't show up the [ __ ] yet to
show you eating this is me doing setup
get the [ __ ] outta I show you for the
most important thing to get your head
together you understand me that's the
most important thing soon as you get
your head together
you [ __ ] them back to normal you do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you can stab
my [ __ ] me a PhD you can for
the [ __ ] of tiny right what do you
think one more [ __ ] bone out of
respect and I know you got [ __ ] the door
people to see I ain't here to [ __ ]
slow you what the [ __ ] is up or your
truth you know I'm here for one thing
only I came to get down I can't forget
them jump around jump around jump jump
jump talking to get down are you [ __ ]
one more just for the road they [ __ ]
let it skinned and said alright what do
you think one more for the road won't do
one more why do I do this because I love
you [ __ ] I read again I will
you guys via this [ __ ] periscope can
any other [ __ ] people in the world
this is what it's all about 10 years ago
we never dreamed of this [ __ ] right now
we're in our living rooms getting stoned
to the [ __ ] gills together who's
better than us nobody after this you
have a little dinner you take a little
[ __ ] you give the wife a stabbing
BAM you watch a little Dancing with the
Stars you jump up and down you smoke
another few [ __ ] bones and that's it
you wake up on it's Thursday and you've
won understand oh you don't get shot we
don't get malaria in your [ __ ] you
want Joe wasn't the chitter-chatter
spark that soldier
[Music]
you don't meet them I show up I got
three wise men with a [ __ ] a bullet
my got time to show up
I didn't snap again we die with no bleed
okay I got it now so I got like this
safe I got it the [ __ ] car yeah at my
wife's clock and down the block at the
arrows house you know but what I just
got a couple pounds at the house
but this is it we do this can we move on
for the rest of it and that's it we got
to see each other we got to talk to each
other got to look at you my eyes Jimmy
jr. was over there C Corp this right now
running things my little nephew Timmy
Julia and that's it what do you want
from me I'm over here [ __ ] up just
like you right now right now I'm getting
[ __ ] way from from the underworld
Joey Joey come back don't do it
and that's it you know I love you
[ __ ] tomorrow night podcast
8:00 p.m. be there be square I know
you're busy you get your dicks up you
know you do what you do see what I'm
saying ever since I did in fact the
police Oh [ __ ] breathing exercises my
jujitsu better my previous look better
my skin looks better my thickest honor
that's dr. police to show up with some
[ __ ] half a home the teacher had a
brief understand doctor police is like
50 cuz she's still got it
but I love you [ __ ] stay black
have a good night stay safe we'll join
loves your logs [ __ ] hot
I'll see you guys tomorrow night 8
o'clock no I will not be done then throw
out I said it they kill